Welcome to the mini-project on regressions.
If you worked at Enron in 2000 or
2001, chances are you're getting a pretty hefty bonus.
How hefty? Well that's what we're going to to figure out in this lesson using
the power of regressions.
So, if you know someone's salary, if you know someone's stock options,
et cetera, et cetera,
are you able to predict how much money they're making in their bonus every year.
And the answer is, well, maybe, but you have to use a regression to find out.
So that's what we'll be doing.
In the second part of the mini project, we're going to get a sneak peek at
next lesson's material, which is about outliers.
Outliers are data points that fall far outside the pattern as a large, and
you'll get an idea of, of how those actually affect the result that you get
on something like your regression.
It can be bigger than you might think.